what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
we are prepping to go to WonderCon right
now it looks like we found our topics
for our panel yes it's gonna be a fun
one it's gonna be enjoy his occasion no
we're gonna have our owner comp panel
talking about the current state of the
MCU and DCU fandom with that while
searching there was two stories that
were consistently popping up on our
feeds the reasons are obvious as to why
that would be the case we're going to
talk about two things today one these
Harley Quinn Lady Gaga set photos and
another story which is very much
connected to the same thing this one is
like now completely overshadowing that
one at the time filming this Jonathan
majors has been arrested so um let's
start with the positive one first one
more positive one right
and then we'll end this in a really dark
place just a way that you want to do
your videos that's how you you leave
your audience feeling leave them on a
bum note but you guys can uh leave a
like on your way out so yeah these
Harley Quinn said photos I thought were
pretty cool actually were these outside
of John outside of like a courthouse and
they're all protesting to free the Joker
there's a crowd gathered many clown
masks Easter eggs abound if you guys
watch my trailer reaction that I did for
that 15 second teaser I gave a plot
Theory and I still feel like the movie
is going to be going down the path that
I've been predicting and seeing here
they have like even some video where I
can't quite tell if she's being escorted
down the stairs or being escorted up the
stairs they're just resetting the tape
there's conflicting videos here I think
he's gonna kill it I feel like the
second shoot was castle and perfect
casting Perfect cast especially for an
actress who takes her work methodically
serious will definitely be able to give
a portrayal that is in the universe of
this Dark World of Joker distinguish
herself from what Margot Robbie's been
doing in live action and what you got
here is something that feels very
natural and doesn't feel overly
heightened it looks kind of like a
ground I think about it looks kind of
like a cross between her as like quinzel
and uh Harley Quinn exactly taking the
Harley Quinn patterns and color palettes
but applying it to a more smart
functional business attire kind of
approach yeah yeah something else that
people have been noticing images that
they have that are clearly not just in
reference to Harvey Dent they're about
Harvey yes directly by name signs that
say Harvey Dent is a clown there's
multiple signs of that it would appear
the way how Thomas Wayne was utilized in
the Joker movie that they would probably
utilize Harvey Dent that way like I
don't think he would become two-faced in
this film but I imagine district
attorney Harvey Dent will play role
probably the one who keeps Joker Behind
Bars which would make sense if they're
saying Harvey Dent is a clown he's the
one making sure Arthur Fleck is being
prosecuted then you got quinzel who's
probably the psychiatrist saying like he
shouldn't be left here or something like
that yeah yeah he should be criminally
convicted he should be put in some kind
of Hospital put into some kind of care
and they probably want to see him you
know paid and hit with the book like it
also like the more we hear about this
the more it seems like maybe this could
Arch into a bigger franchise because I
think it would be cool if we got a just
Harvey Dent presence in Folia do and
then wait till later to make him
two-faced just get the really deep
two-faced one it's not even like a
messed up face yeah yeah that's just a
bad scholar yeah he's got like a Freddy
Krueger bird on half his face he's just
really self-conscious that's not a bad
call it's not a bad Theory you got there
yeah what do you think about these
Harley Quinn set photos I think she
looks great and I I'm really excited for
the direction that this is going to end
up evolving into John I think it's only
appropriate that you segue us into our
next topic uh but of course speaking of
Smash Hits
Jesus Christ speaking of inappropriate
humor should I come out that stays in
the video oh good okay uh yeah no no
speaking of no laughing uh matters
Jonathan majors has been arrested in New
York I think we're gonna get in trouble
let's say it's in the video
Even though I control the setting I'm
gonna decide
okay every once in a while we all need
to be with our feet above the fire it
says these celebrities are a bunch of
dumbasses yeah yeah yeah I don't want to
tell proven guilty though I don't want
to trivialize anybody's pain it's
interesting because there has been a
tweet circulating actually uh reposted
today as a segue somebody has posted
that there's a particular actor
relatively new on the scene who Twitter
has violently Fallen head over heels for
who's actually a vicious cruel abusive
human being both professionally and in
his personal life and every new viral
thirst tweet about him drives me insane
people have been reposting that and the
person who posted that redid it today
with a ding ding ding so it's an
interesting uh development here because
Jonathan Majors obviously has this sort
of beloved personality and this is the
last thing you would want to hear about
someone who stars on the rise in the way
that his has been but yeah he has
apparently been arrested and I guess let
go as of the moment uh you know for
assaulting somebody in a New York taxi
cab yeah the way the story goes
according to um the highly respectable
TMZ the way the story goes is that while
in a cab major Major's girlfriend and
all this is alleged we got to keep that
in mind it's all legends a woman was
texting him he did not respond kindly to
that grabbed her hand and slapped her
allegedly put her hands around her neck
and supposedly the resources that say
the alleged victim had invisible
injuries including a laceration behind
her ear redness and marks to her face
yeah these are pretty serious charges
Jonathan Majors reps say that he did
nothing wrong so pretty much it was not
what happened and let's not do this we
look forward to clearing his name I know
there was a time where whenever
something came out people immediately
presumed this person was guilty you know
and I don't want to spend so much time
speculating
as a matter of fact there's a reason why
putting both stories here in this one
video because we don't have a ton
of thoughts on any of this yeah
and this situation right here we just
gotta wait to see how it unfolds it's
really unfortunate yes as a fan of
Jonathan Majors it is saddening
especially if this is true like it's a
really messed up situation and it's a
really messed up action if he actually
did do this and should be condemned for
it you know but we did letters or Miller
ago so we might as well just uh watch
the next you know King Dynasty movie oh
yeah yeah we got money to make don't
forget that the bottom line but more
importantly if it is true um whomever
this woman is I feel terrible for her
because we know how situations like this
go if it ends up being true somehow in
this whole process and this whole
journey she can still get some type of
heat a lot of negative attention oh yeah
purposely or just the fact that she's
getting attention for this in general
it's replaying the trauma and then
you've got people who are going to
behave really ugly on top of that it's
not a pleasant situation all around I
don't know what to believe simply
because we don't really have much
information right now however it's not
the major is something that we've talked
essentially about on this channel and um
definitely got our DMS asking thoughts
about it so here's our thoughts waiting
to see what happens and we don't know
what that'll be but hopefully that
people in the healing process of this
situation because you know if it is true
God damn it that is horrible if
it's not true yeah the Matrix himself
has to deal with having that you know
mark on his name because now that it's
out there it's never not gonna be
thought of exactly because there's
already a lot of people who would
immediately presume it is true and it's
something that would follow someone
around even if it isn't I hope it's not
it's yeah it's a it's the last thing you
want to hear especially for somebody in
this position but all that aside yeah
it's just the worst kind of situation
you could find yourself in and I have to
feel for anybody who's coming forward
with a you know a story like that
because you know you're going to be
persecuted by people who love this guy
alrighty guys well what do you think
about this story I'm sure it's a fun
thing to engage on the internet about it
sure leave your thoughts down below
other cooler talk
um yeah uh I think it's good to enter
right here
um yeah and then really dark place and
yes no we don't need to go any further
yeah just leave it here yeah no need to
shout anybody out in the dark video no I
don't I feel like that would be
unnatural uh let's let's call it a day
guys we're off to wonder being good to
each other we'll see you guys
foreign